also please follow the discussions
taking place
respectfully on the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
more than uh more than 26 000 can you
imagine
more than 20 these are numbers no one's
ever seen before
more than 26 000 of our viewers and
listeners
uh participating in the discussion up
one user
suggests i was checking out some of the
discussions this morning
one of our viewers says i think there's
a 95
chance republicans will try to impeach
biden on day one
going on to say honestly i'm not even
being facetious i think they'll start
bringing forward articles of impeachment
the minute biden is sworn in we all know
what's the first thing they're going to
try to impeach him for they will argue
biden is an illegitimate president due
to mass voter fraud
and election rigging in the 2020
presidential election
they might also cite ukraine scandals
being unfit for office or
cognitive impairment or make up a
corruption story
um i i don't expect uh
impeachment um articles to be filed
against biden
right away but i would certainly i mean
listen this is one of the most
weaponized republican parties we've
we've seen as long as i've been
following politics closely
which i would say at this point is about
you know 20 years
um this is one of the most weaponized
republican parties so i wouldn't be
surprised at some point
to see an attempt at impeaching joe
biden and again
this is why uh democrats have control of
the house
and control of the senate is in question
based on the january 5th
senate runoffs in georgia if democrats
control the house and the senate it puts
these fears
essentially to bed uh another post from
the david pakman show subreddit
which is not as convinced that the
december 14th
elector vote is the end saying
it should be over with the electors
having voted but
trump supporters among them elected
officials are holding their delusions
close
and vowing to disrupt the certification
of ballots on january 6th
even after that the inauguration could
be targeted i keep wanting to celebrate
and see us moving on but unlike the
trumpists i see the clear reality
that we are not out of the woods and
more insane even violent actions are
still a possibility sorry to say
i actually am i'm less worried about a
disruption on january 6.
i assume that some republican members of
the house will stand and object
when certain state elector votes
electoral votes are being counted
maybe even some members of the senate
will stand and say uh mr speaker or
whoever
you know mr senate president which is
going to be mike pence at the time i
object
but i don't think that's going to go
anywhere the violence does concern me
more because
at at any point there's a tinderbox
situation here if trump says the wrong
thing or the right thing depending on
your perspective
i think the the sycophants are ready to
go absolutely
crazy claiming they are defending who
the person they believe to be
that they see as the rightful winner of
the 2020 election so
that worries me more than any serious
disruption to the process
on january 6th let me know if you
disagree
and join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit